the viewers who are not that familiar
with positions that we would never dare
to speculate about this kind of things
if there would be real tension in the
position Black's problem is however that
he is forced with the the decision that
he has to depart from his Rook on
History he can't play the move to K8 yes
and there is a handshake Rook takes E1
followed by a draw for nothing nothing
left to do
and the players amicably discussing uh
this game perhaps a quick discussion of
the opening Theory a great choice by
Magnus Carlson to play the album so
heads up he knew the theory and uh after
he played Knight takes D4 and brought
his Queen out to F3 it started becoming
clear uh that prague's winning chances
were just non-existent and in typical
professional clean style Magnus Carlson
secures victory at the 2023 Worlds Cup
as we just said the final feather in his
cap which had been eluding him